welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka h from steps and mother of god
was line of duty a big disappointment
after 10 years of teasing who the fourth
man was
we finally discovered the true culprit
and it went down worse than dominic
cummings at boris johnson's flat warming
party
throughout this video we're gonna be
explaining the show's ending
answering its big questions and giving
our thoughts on why it might be the next
game
of thrones full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out yet
then i highly recommend that you check
out now
smash the thumbs up button if you were
disappointed in the show as well
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our ending
explained of line of duty
okay so episode 7 has a lot going on
with it
and though the series ended pretty badly
the show as a whole has been one of the
most talked about things on the bbc
since that elephant had a [ __ ] on blue
peter it's been 60 years mate yeah
you can stop going on about it now
anyway light of duty is an incredibly
gripping show that will have you so
involved you start to suspect your
grandma is h
because she spells definitely wrong now
my american viewers may look at this and
think it's a sequel to hot fuzz
but it has to be said that up until last
night it was one of the best shows we
had
the season as a whole primarily centered
around a journalist called gail bella
who was assassinated because she got too
close to the connection between
hashtag bent coppers and organized crime
unlike most of the other highly
fictionalized seasons
we metaphorically touched upon real-life
crimes namely the tragic murder of
stephen lawrence
which was changed to lawrence
christopher through ac12's investigation
we saw the extent of systemic corruption
and racism within the force
as we watched how the key characters
involved in this were protected by the
higher-ups in the police
and their organized crime family on the
outside at points season six has felt
like a bit of a trip down memory lane
and ac12 have touched upon several
previous characters like tommy hunter
philip osborne ian buckles terry boyle
and a guy who could become a millionaire
overnight if he sold dartboards with his
face on it
and don't even get me started on you
love
ted hastings has been forced to retire
so he's now getting in
as many tedisms as he can steve honor is
facing the sack for his painkiller
addiction
and kate was perhaps getting too close
to the one person
that she shouldn't have been like every
season so far
at the center of it has been a brand new
bent copper named joanne davidson
in the series we discovered that she was
related to tommy hunter
who was both her father and uncle see i
told you it was like game of thrones
now in the finale we learned that she
had been coerced into believing that a
bent copper was actually the one behind
it
and after being promised a life and
witness protection she revealed this to
be patrick fairbank
fairbank was jailed in 2015 due to
carrying
out years of abuse at sandview's boy's
home it did seem like his dementia could
all have been an
act and that he might be the mastermind
behind it all
however a search of his cell came up
with nothing and the whole connection to
fairbank turned out to be a lie just to
keep joe in the dark
this led ac 12 to go back to the drawing
board and
look at the evidence once more namely
any communication
where definitely was spelt incorrectly
we went over all the notes we had
and watched as ac12 uncovered the truth
this led them to find out that the
person they'd been chasing for years
this mysterious shadow in the dark was
ian buckles all
along oh go [ __ ] yourself buckles
throughout the series has been the kind
of
idiot that would run track and trace on
an excel spreadsheet
and he makes officer doofy look like
colombo
initially he started off giving no
comment like a bad subscriber
however after ac ac12 connected the dot
he started to reveal the inner workings
of the ocg
turns out that tommy hunter was the one
originally running it all
but after he died the ocg ended up
dividing into smaller factions
buckle was put in place as the
communicator that would pass on
information between these groups
all whilst relaying orders to the police
that were on the inside
every time a message was sent through a
laptop he was the one behind it
and though not specifically h himself
buckles is the ghost that ac 12 have
been chasing
he was absolutely loaded but had been
tricking everyone by wearing cheap suits
taking holidays to butlins and refusing
to get around in
which was one of the worst crimes of all
i think that the show very much
wanted this to be their kaiser souza
moment because let's be real
buckles is an absolute [ __ ] he's so
incompetent that he'd probably get the
top job in uk government
and i feel like the creative team behind
it wanted us to very much think that it
had been an
outstanding act to throw us off
suspicion
i don't really think it worked though
buckles even had davidson frame him
in order to shine light on someone else
and from inside his jail cell he sent
orders through a laptop
and a burner phone he tried to gain
witness protection and play the group
but they revealed that as he had already
answered all the questions they were
after
that that deal was off the table at the
end of the entry we watched as buckles
was moved to the vulnerable
prisoners unit within a supermax and
discovered that there was a motion to
suppress
any evidence of corruption in court so
that it couldn't be used against him
this means that there is likely still
corruption in the police force
and during his final press conference
osborne stated that any bent coppers
were simply just bad apples now it's
highly like that because of this motion
that osborne himself is involved in the
corruption
as we know from the events of season six
that he is a key person
in limiting the resources and work that
ac 12 have
we also learned that officers close to
him have been promoted to senior
positions
making it seem like this is just the
beginning of something new
there's a hydra feel to it where if he
cut off the head of one corrupt officer
two more will grow back in its place not
sure if that metaphor works but you get
the gist of it now as for ac 12
they've been left at possibly the lowest
point they've ever been at
however it does seem like there could
still be hope in the episode hastings
ended up revealing the true extent of
what happened to the missing 50 000
pounds
and we learned that it had been used to
buy ppe from his public sorry it had
had been used to help steph corbett
financially now after believing that he
likely led to the death of john corbett
hastings said that he wanted to ease
some of the guilt and help her in a way
in which no one would get hurt
both kate and steve remained silent over
this but hastings did reveal it to
carmichael along with the fact that he
informed lee banks of an undercover
officer within his unit
what carmichael does with this
information we don't know
but judging by her reaction and the fact
that we hear nothing more of it in the
show
it's likely that this was being kept
between her and ted
now this kind of leads me into my season
seven predictions and though
nothing has been greenlit yet someone
needs to come in and rescue this show
because i say i tell you what yeah if
this is the last if this is the last
season yeah
i'll be absolutely fuming now personally
i think that carmichael will end up
leading the smaller anti-corruption
group going forward
and that hastings will work alongside
her in the pub scene at the end kate
herself also hints that she wants to
rejoin her former team again
and work once more with ted and steve i
think this means that we could have more
seasons going off that tackle different
issues
and also different characters come on
yeah a pay me license fee for this kind
of stuff
i don't care about anything else just
just do another season please
let's be honest at this point line of
duty was starting to buckle
under its own mythology and it was
almost impossible for them to have a
satisfying conclusion
with all of the spinning plates that
they currently had therefore i think
that the best move
is to just do as a sort of soft reboot
with a brand new team of officers
overseen from time to time by steve kate
and ted
they very much wanted to put a pin in
this series and wrap up the entire thing
with h
but going forward i believe that they
should focus on smaller stories each
season
rather than having an overarching one in
which everyone is mephisto
sorry the fourth man now other questions
you may have are over what happened to
thurwell
aka james nesbitt because of a big name
actor being behind the role
a lot of us suspected that he was the
one calling the shots from behind the
scenes
and that the finale might even set him
up for a season 7 arc
however we learned that the character
was dead and that it was indeed his body
in the spanish apartment
farewell or rather nesbit was simply a
decoy that's probably the
easiest acting job that james nesbitt
has ever had
i think this character perfectly
summarizes my thoughts for the season as
a whole
and that we were expecting something big
to come from it
but in the end it was a bit of a nothing
burger
like nesbit h was built up to be
something big
and we as audiences got invested in the
mystery
creating our own theories as the show
went on
every time something like this happens
one of the first replies that you get is
well it's your own fault for making it
so big
you shouldn't have theorized and grabbed
on the clues that they were dropping
every single episode
now you might be writing some shows
saying that yeah but in the case of line
of duty
i disagree with that the show could have
easily have put the pin in the whole age
of mystery years and years ago
and to drag something out for a decade
it's ultimately going to increase the
hype behind it as well
that's why the ending just feels so
disappointing and to see
fuming trending last night on twitter i
think sums up the feeling of the uk
line of gt was good up until this point
but it did fail to stick the landing
that's why i have such great admiration
for shows like breaking bad
and films like avengers end game as it's
rare that we get satisfying conclusions
when it comes to things that have been
staples for a large part of our lives
it's a difficult one to recommend
because i know there is a lot of good in
line of duty
but at the same time it does feel
slightly formulaic
every season is pretty much the same
thing and though a couple of tedisms
here and there yeah
they keep you on board i'm looking back
a bit like
what was the point i feel no more
satisfied at the end of season six than
i did at the end of season one
i think this show is very much a victim
of the bbc wanting to keep recapturing
lightning in a bottle
i did quite enjoy season six in all of
its build-up
but ultimately in the end i just think
it feels a bit hollow
buckles doesn't seem like the person
that they knew was going to be h in the
beginning
and his reveal as the fourth man feels
very tacked on
had they set him up much earlier i think
that this would have worked to greater
effect
i'm hoping that we do get a seventh
season that goes back to the drawing
board
to handle things with more of a plan
ultimately line of gt was a show with a
great setup
but a meh ending and for me it'll sit
alongside
series the likes of game of thrones and
lost as i think about what could have
been
we end up much like joe hoping for a
better tomorrow
and going off into what could be a new
start
also yeah if if i get a house in a bird
like that from witness protection yeah
sign me up because i'm spoiling
everything god damn
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the finale so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kung collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the finale the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
say that to you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers have you want
something else to watch something
a bit better then definitely check out
our breakdown of the ending of
invincible
we went over the season finale and all
of its comic book callbacks
so definitely check it out right after
this without the way thank you for
sticking through the video
i've been paul and i see you next time
take care
[Music]
peace